s'agit donc de marielle de sarnez qui
est vice présidente du modem et qui est
députée européenne est-ce que cet
express vous l'avez reçu exprès parce
que nous sommes aujourd'hui le 8 mars
ont bien sûr et puis la sélection
départementale donc un jour et on
souhaite
la voilà la charte dans les studios et
les espoirs du modem à quinze jours donc
de ces élections départementales
marielle de sarnez vice présidente du
modem député européenne bonjour
bienvenue dans son studio
d'abord l'actualité de ces dernières
heures claude guéant mise en examen hier
soir pour faux et usage de faux et
blanchiment de fraude fiscale en bande
organisée claude guéant ancien ministre
de l'intérieur ancien secrétaire général
de l'elysée ancien directeur général de
la police nationale votre réaction
aucun commentaire que la justice fasse
son travail moi j'ai tout à fait
confiance en la justice de mon pays
n'avait pas le sentiment que ça peut
porter une ombre sur la classe politique
quand je vous ai dit aucun commentaire
c'est que j'ai vraiment bien l'intention
de ne pas aller bavarder sur un dossier
que je ne connais pas c'est aujourd'hui
marielle de sarnez la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
sondage ifop dont le journal du dimanche
ce matin les femmes politiques préférées
des français
première christine lagarde secondes de
marine le pen troisième ségolène royal
vous êtes 19e
marielle de sarnez comment faire encore
avancer les droits des femmes en 2015
y a pas que les femmes politiques les
femmes politiques c'est important mais
moi je pense aujourd'hui journée des
femmes à toutes les femmes qui sont moi
je trouve ce sont des héroïnes
formidable et femmes qu'elles sont
courageuses qu'elle se batte qu'elles
sont sur tous les fronts qu'elle assume
tout qu'elle assure
voilà j'ai envie de leur rendre hommage
après ben il faut continuer de
travailler il faut continuer de
travailler en france on a encore des
inégalités importantes vous le savez
bien et inégalités dans les salaires
inégalités dans les responsabilités
c'est plus difficile pour une femme
d'accéder aux responsabilités pour un
homme
bah il faut que ça change il faut que ça
progresse aussi en europe
et puis on peut pas ne pas penser aux
femmes qui sont dans le monde et qui ont
des combats difficiles des vies dures
qui sont discriminés voilà ils y ont
tous ensemble aujourd'hui une pensée
pour toutes ces femmes formidables et
vous avez vu pire que les mentalités
changent c'est que vous vous en
réjouissez particulièrement parce
qu'elle eut un sondage bva opinion pour
orange et i télé qui a été diffusé hier
selon lequel neuf français sur dix sont
prêts à élire une femme présidente de la
république
morgan est sérieuse c'est excellent
voilà une bonne nouvelle les élections
départementales dont dans deux semaines
que dites vous ce matin à tous ces
électeurs nombreux qui ont l'intention
de s'abstenir lors de ces départemental
les sondages annoncent 56 % d'abstention
mais je vais vous comment je vais
peut-être vous surprendre mais je les
comprends pour partie on est dans un
espèce de schéma institutionnel local
incompréhensible illisible les français
ont du mal à faire la part des choses on
est en train de créer des communautés de
communes des métropoles des grandes
régions on devait supprimer les
départements
finalement on en garde certains pas tous
et après on dit ah comme c'est étonnant
les français vont pas aller voter
beaucoup écouté il faut que les
responsables politiques qui sont aux
manettes soit cohérent si on a envie que
les français votent à des élections
locales
il faut que le sens de ces élections
locales soient simples compréhensibles
lisible par les citoyens c'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui
le modem est aujourd'hui un parti
d'opposition
c'est un parti qui a sa propre nature
qui est on va dire différent des autres
c'est à dire que quand la majorité fait
quelque chose de bien nous disons par
exemple sur la loi macron moi je
trouvais que c'était pas exceptionnel
mais que ça allait plutôt dans le bon
sens on le dit mais à la vérité ce que
je crois c'est que les partis
d'opposition devraient aussi avoir ce
type d'attitude
c'est à dire que l'ump ou en tous les
cas le centre devrait évidemment
soutenir quand ça va dans la bonne
direction
ça n'empêche qu'ensuite vous vous
opposez sur des questions qui sont
importantes et lourdes
mais je considère que vous ça
et que depuis longtemps que la
bipolarisation c'est à dire cette espèce
de manière qui a d'un côté une majorité
alors tout ce qu'elle fait c'est
forcément moche pour l'opposition de
l'autre côté l'opposition qui attend
simplement que la majorité se casse la
figure
ça fait 30 ans que ça dure en france et
c'est très mauvais pour la france
cela dit pour ces départemental le modem
aligne trois cent quarante deux
candidats majoritairement au sein
d'alliance avec l'ump ou eu des ja de
l'alliance large bien sûr puisque ce
sont plutôt du côté ump on est descente
va pas du ressort que la gauche on est
au centre
on est au centre n'ont écouté les
alliances avec le parti socialiste
regardez parti socialiste a même été
incapable au fond d'approuver
globalement la loi macron ça veut dire
qu'il a quand même un problème de
positionnement et d'ouverture au monde
donc nous sommes dans des alliances
large dans des rassemblements larges
on a très bon candidat et je suis
heureuse de dire qu'on aura plusieurs
petite centaine d'élus ce qui est très
très bien mais face à la dureté de la
crise marielle de sarnez est ce qu'il
faudrait pas des choix clairs trancher
tout le contraire du modem avec sont ni
droite ni gauche on a un peu du mal à
voir votre ligne politique c'est à dire
que si vous pensez qu'avec la droite 4
la gauche évidemment vous pouvez pas
sixième cas des millions de français qui
se retrouve pas la dent et à des
millions de français qui se
reconnaissent pas dans la caricature
d'un côté c'est noir de l'autre côté
c'est blanc nous sommes au centre
nous avons des alliances et des
partenariats avec le centre avec le
centre-droit et avec une droite on va
dire républicaine et c'est bien ainsi
c'est important d'affirmer son identité
le centre et en même temps nous sommes
dans les temps où il faut être capable
d'avoir des alliances cas pas d'avoir
des partenariats moi je crois d'ailleurs
que pour le pays
on le verra aux prochaines élections
présidentielles il faudra aller beaucoup
plus loin
on ne réformera pas durablement la
france si on n'a pas des majorité très
large
giscard c'était il ya longtemps disait
que va les réunir deux français sur
trois est bien dans ce salon grand
l'avait profondément raison quelles sont
les grandes réformes dont la france a
besoin
on a besoin de retrouver confiance en
nous
a besoin de créer une espèce de biotope
qui soit favorable à la création à
l'entreprise à tout ce qui produit de la
richesse
on a besoin par exemple de réformer
notre système de retraite on n'arrivera
pas à faire ce type de réforme camp
contre camp et donc c'est ça que le
centre porte avec françois bayrou et moi
même et d'autres nombreux depuis
longtemps le secrétaire d'état aux
relations avec le parlement le
socialiste jean marie le guen déclare ce
matin dans le jdd que la lutte contre le
front national est prioritaire c'est une
menace majeure le fn vous êtes d'accord
moi je considère que le fn sa force
d'aujourd'hui elle est venue de la
faiblesse du monde politique depuis
trente ans et de cette bipolarisation
que je que je récuse que je combats ça
fait 30 ans qu'on élit à chaque fois des
responsables qu'ils soient socialistes
qu'ils soient ump qui promettent des
mots et des merveilles qui ne tiennent à
peu près aucun leurs engagements et donc
je pense qu'on est dans un cycle
politique il faut profondément
révolutionner changé mais vous êtes tous
les responsables soient les roues a été
ministre
françois bayrou a été ministre
d'ailleurs un très bon ministre de
l'éducation nationale mais enfin le
centre je dois le reconnaître n'a pas
été au pouvoir en tant que tel depuis
très longtemps
non moi je crois qu'il faut faire bouger
les lignes je crois par exemple il faut
une réforme du mode du scrutin
on peut pas continuer avec une assemblée
nationale c'est le jour de la journée
des femmes parlons-en qui représente
absolument pas les sensibilités
politiques du pays en la 90% de
parlementaires d'ailleurs une immense
majorité d'hommes qui représente à peine
45 % peut-être des électeurs français
moi je rêve d'un parlement avec sans
doute moins de députés
mais qui représente la république qui
soit aux couleurs de la république et
dans lequel y ait autant de femmes que
d'hommes
voilà une réforme pourquoi le front
national prospère comme je me ils
prospèrent parce que au fond les
français se disent l'ump a échoué le ps
a échoué il va falloir qu'on essaye
autre chose et ils prospèrent parce que
les français ont envie d'envoyer un
message de défiance à leur classe
politique et donc moi je dis une chose
il faut que les responsables politiques
prennent leurs responsabilités et qu'ils
acceptent de changer qu'ils acceptent de
bouger il faut que le monde politique
change et évolue et soit capable de
faire bouger
les lignes ci restent figés dans des
espèces de certitudes et caricatures
d'hier et d'avant-hier il faut pas
qu'ils s'étonnent de ce qui se passe
mais encore une fois on a du mal à
saisir votre position nicolas sarkozy a
dit hier que françois bayrou n'est pas
dans l'opposition parce que françois
bayrou a précisé qu'il n'aurait pas voté
la toute récente motion de censure
visant le gouvernement
et en même temps il ya des alliances
très nombreuses avec l'ump ou udi écouté
l'exposé 4 si vous n'arrivez pas à
comprendre réfléchissent et 4 secondes
comme françois bayrou dit qu'il votera
pas la motion de censure la motion de
censure avait porté sur quoi sur la loi
macron moi je fais partie des millions
de français françois aussi qui considère
que la loi macron c'est peut-être pas
extraordinaire mais que c'est une
avancée
alors on se dit quoi si c'est une
avancée vaut mieux le voter que de ne
pas le voter
et donc vous devriez comprendre que au
fond il ya des millions de français qui
ont envie que les politiques ils
prennent en compte un principe de
réalité qui fasse des choses qui sont
bonnes pour le pays et qu'ils arrêtent
d'avoir purement et simplement comme le
dirait sarkozy matin midi et soir comme
il le fait des réflexes de partis qui
sont au fond des réflexes qui ne tirent
pas la politique galop marielle de
sarnez au deuxième tour des
départementales en cas de duel ps fn
qu'est ce que vous faites qu'est ce que
vous dites à vous et les que nous sommes
absolument constant nous au centre et la
de ce point de vue là nous nous
garderons le cap qui est le nôtre nous
voterons pour le candidat qui sera
contre celui du front national nous
voterons pour le candidat socialiste
marielle de sarnez vice présidente du
modem député européenne merci beaucoup
verts crc pts et l'invitation de france
inter ce matin patricia martin merveille
c'est formidable vous avez parlé de la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes vous êtes un homme merveilleux
mais absolument il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire et marielle de sarnez
l'a rappelé sur le plan professionnel
sur le plan salarial ce qui est un peu
surprenant quand même c'est que
christine lagarde est considérée comme
étant la femme politique préférée des
français je rappelle qu'elle a déclaré
tout récemment après l'amour du roi
abdallah d'arabie saoudite que le roi
abdallah était un grand défenseur des
femmes
non je suis d'accord je partage pas du
tout son opinion simplement je crois que
les français sont fiers d'avoir une
française à la tête du fmi
voilà et tout le monde peut dire des
bêtises les hommes et les femmes
c'est ça l'égalité ou encore quelquefois
les hommes plus que les femmes